yep it's going
all right as chair of the house ways and
means committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of covert 19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive audit 20
this public body is authorized to me
electronically
this is a work session
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaries into this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order and confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporariously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaries listen and if necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website
the notice for this meeting complies the
house rules
and rsa 91a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call 271
3600 or email
hcs like.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us
jennifer iv committee research
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting should be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call of attendance
when each member stakes their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
which is required under the right to
know law representative bernstein you
want to take the role
thank you mr chair and good morning to
you today is may 18
2021 and as you all know it's brooks
robinson's birthday today so you'll join
me in wishing the hall of fame
third baseman a happy birthday uh
we'll begin roll call with
[Music]
substituting for representative mary
griffin is representative david love
welcome to ways and means
you're muted right now say good morning
to us
uh good morning ellen this is
representative david love i'm here alone
okay thank you for joining us
representatives
we have to show us i think on a roll
call vote he'll have to show his
handsome face um
back to whoa i can't get it get my feet
yeah um
work on it maybe re-log in with your
phone
we'll let you work that out while we
continue representative ovary
yes i'm here in hudson my wife is in the
house someplace
other than that you'll notice the pile
on the desk is getting smaller
we all noticed that actually
okay we'll come back to representative
albert representative
doucette morning mr clerk i join you
alone for my home office how do you hear
me
so i'm going to mark representative ober
as here
and i interrupted representative doucet
my apologies
no worries good morning home alone in
salem
your clerk is alan bursty and i'm in my
home office in nottingham new hampshire
by myself
hey uh representative canigian
yes i'm here i'm actually on vacation
and um i'm currently alone but my wife
and daughter could
enter the room representative nunes
good morning mr clerk i am home alone in
beautiful pelham new hampshire
representative baxter thank you mr clerk
i'm home alone
and i'm going to sign in on my phone
that way i can take votes when needed
excellent representative stillsbury
good morning i'm home in charlestown
with a son in the home
here in northwood home alone
representative army
you're in lebanon hello representative
ames
i'm here in jeffrey in my home office
alone
representative southworth
representative southworth now
representative malloy
i'm here alone in greenland
good morning representative the
honorable
representative thomas schamberg good
morning
representative bergstein it's great to
hear your tenor voice i'm here in
wilmette
in my office my wife's at the doctor's
office thank you
thank you representative tucker
in randolph alone representative go
marlow
aaron swansea alone representative
laughman
representative gorg good morning i am
present and alone
good morning representative phillips
morning
come to you from my office alone in
concord
representative james murphy good morning
i am alone at home in hanover
morning and chairman norman major good
morning i'm
in my home implants did you hear me at
actually representative ober we we can
hear you
um mr chair there are 21 members present
just a wrap up of what we're going to be
doing today
we're going to be a work session
an executive session on senate bill
we'll be dealing with an amendment that
we will discuss senate bill 3
then we want to take action
on what the senate sent
us on house bill 630
and 533 and
see what the consensus of the committee
is but we want to concur the senate
none concur the senate or
non-concur the senate from a committee
tomorrow we'll be meeting at 10 o'clock
10 o'clock we will be meeting with
members of the
chamber of commerce to talk about
with their members gathering information
on what
they applied for on ppp loans have they
been forgiven
and etc on various types of businesses
and then we'll have emily swanson back
where she has now
has the latest scoop on what the rules
are
on the american recovery funds and
hopefully we'll get some good news on
that
and i'm going to be sending everybody a
copy of the
wall street journal article i read this
morning
which says a judicial blow to biden's
tax cut brand
where the looks like
the stipulation of not having anything
offset taxes may be in jeopardy
and so i'll send that to everybody this
morning
mr chairman are we going to do
concurrence on house bill
565 at some point you could send it to
uh thanks for reminding me of that uh
yes
i have a question mr chair
yes um you said emily swanson
did you mean emily brock
tomorrow
hold on one second the same woman that
her name is emily swenson brock
okay thank you this didn't go far enough
thank you mr chair uh
yes representatives um back to
house bill 565 which representative
omni brought up i'm not sure that's in a
posture for
concur or not concur the senate
table 565. they passed and then tabled
it
i didn't send it over here it is uh
i think is it
uh it's in house bill 100 not senate
bill 100
that hasn't come forward either so so
that's
why we haven't taken that okay because
all i have
from from the clerk
uh three packages of the three bills i
just read
and i was going to check after this
meeting i was going to check on what the
565 was because
i don't remember getting that package on
that
i think it's in edna but did we
talk did the committee talk to them
about
i'm going to have to review that
which one was that again that do we know
it's
the charitable gaming commission
committee
study uh yeah
there it wasn't it was in uh
it was a omnibus bill
that went to legislative administration
and uh and i i testified and
senator d'alessandro testified his
agreement
with me and us because i told him that i
was representing the ways and means as
well as myself
and uh this is going to be the an
amendment
to change our makeup of of our piece of
the commission committee
uh which the senate seems senator
d'alessandro was fine with that
uh in that in the hearing so uh
i think what's gonna happen is they'll
pass our bell
and that will be the bill and just keep
but we don't have it yes because it's on
the table
well they may just concur over there
with our change
if all of senate bill 100 gets passed by
legislative administration uh right that
assumes that
i i've been told that should happen but
again there's seven pieces to that
to that bill uh seven different bills
um i was told they're going to mend out
some of them but that
that they were going to keep this and
amend our
our our peace to
reflect the makeup of the committee
of the uh house members excuse me mr
chairman
representative my tech support has
relieved me i am
online and i can talk thank you
by the way i uh uh i was i i thought i
was going to see
we had a chairs meeting yesterday's vice
chairs meeting yesterday
i thought representative hill who was an
in-person meeting so i thought i was
going to see representative hill who
chairs that
legislative administration he wasn't
there i'll track him down to see what
the latest is on
on that bill thank you
right and we won't be doing any
concurring or non-concurring unless we
get from the
clerk
but we can still comment so
norm i misspoke i said that our bell
would be the one it would be
it would be senate bill 100 that would
probably
be the one and it'll just keep our bill
on the table
okay that's probably why
we don't have that in our possession
right
the bills are identical by the way
except for the make up of the committee
okay are we all set to
do senate bill 22 then we're going to
uh executive session on senate bill 22
recognize representative bromley
i uh i make a an ultra pass motion on
senate bill 22.
representative romney next ought to pass
on senate bill
first team on second night
representative bernstein
representative romney i'd like to make
another motion
on uh amendment
uh make a motion that we accept uh
amendment
uh uh 1491 h
so representative romney nixon i'll have
to pass
motion on amendment 1491
h would like to speak to my mother mr
chair
who wants to suck on that note if
president you mean mr chair
representative romney yes
um this amendment is is uh same language
as representative army had in her
amendment last week
uh it deals with section three
uh the way it was written uh
the original bill for section three has
to do with
25 cent uh lucky seven
tickets 50 cent lucky second tickets and
a dollar
lucky seven tickets the way the original
bill was written it says
to offer the dollar ticket you have to
all sell offer
25 and 50 cent tickets as well
uh and we heard that from some of the
uh locations that uh
they may not want to sell uh the 25
ticket but we want to enable them to be
able to do that
so by just eliminating uh
either a 50 cent
uh well we we changed
to not exceed the dollar so
the tickets can not exceed a dollar
but we still keep the requirement that
if you're selling a dollar ticket
you must also sell a 50 cent ticket
which is in current statute
so so basically we just modified the
language slightly
to accommodate the 25 cent ticket
without obligating
a location to have the 25 ticket
because not all the facilities want it
but we retained the concept of if we
if we're going to sell the dollar ticket
that they must
they must they shall offer the dollar
thank you representative romney
representative schamberg
yes thank you mr chairman representative
abrami
on line three it says amend rsa 287
e colon 22.
the reason i bring this up to about 287
is that i see that in house bill
533 on the notes section it says rsa287
was repealed in 1983.
is there has a new one been
talking about the same thing i think
you're talking about a different bill
no well what i'm trying to bring up is
that it says amend rsa287
yet in the house bill 533 the house
research committee put notes over there
and said rsa287
was repealed in 1983.
is this the right rsa number rsa287 is
the
game's a chance and uh
bingo and uh lucky seven statutes we
didn't repeal those so
they didn't repeat okay thank you very
much for that clarification
they're very much in existence yeah if i
may
the 187
[Music]
is the one that was repealed 187e is the
one that's being
spoken of here they're different 187 d
e and so forth 187 or 287
287 sorry okay they're they're
each is a different statute 287
okay thank you same as 287
okay thank you
[Music]
okay are we all set on the status
of 287 versus 287d
any further questions or comments on
amendment 1491 h
let's see then represent bernstein you
want to recall the rules
on the amendment about the pass
you're muted allen thank you
i will begin the roll call vote on
amendment 2021-1491-h with
representative abram
yes
representative david love yes
representative jordan owerry yes
representative fred ducette yes
the clerk votes yes representative
elliott
is not voting
representative thomas southworth
with yes honorable representative thomas
c schambergs
representative schamberg votes yes mr
cork it's nice to see you filing
representative edith tucker yes
representative jennifer gomarlo
tom loffman is not with us
representative james murphy yes
representative and our chair norman
major yes
mr chair the vote is 21 yes
thank you representative bernstein now
we're on
senate bill 22 within
1491 h do i need to make i think i need
to make another motion ought to pass as
amended
is that correct yes i'd like to move
uh senate bill 22
on to pass out to pass moves senate bill
22 with amendment 1491
like to speak to my amendment mr chair
yeah let me just finish writing here
okay run your respective motion emotion
i'm sorry i said a minute
um yeah let's big picture um let's just
recap uh there are we were
these two sections really uh well they
deal with lucky seven
but you can't talk about lucky seven
without talking about bingo
because technically they're only
supposed to be lucky seven tickets
sold when bingo is happening
uh they're they're currently 10
approximately and i
i think i'm copying the numbers down 100
but i think it's around 10
standalone bagel halls in the state that
have a
bingo uh and uh lucky seven license
and uh and they pay uh a fee for that
license
we also have five charitable gaming
halls
that also have they have a terrible
gaming license but they also have a
bingo lucky seven license
to have to to to allow bingo
and lucky seven in in these halls as
well
then there are numerous fraternal
organizations
and as well as lucky seven and many of
these
have the machines so
[Music]
not all of them but some of them have
the machines that one of the things we
want to talk about so lucky seven can be
offered as a pull tab
paper or it could be offered in one of
these
terminals lucky seven terminals
and there are also some venues that also
offer
instead of a human selling the pull tab
ticket
they also have vending machines
in which you can purchase a ticket
at one of these halls where just like a
vending machine
so those are the kind of the three modes
two of the modes
really offer the paper ticket uh and one
is totally electronic
so the first section of the bill deals
with
the the electronic vending machines
not vending machines electronic machines
that basically tell you if you won or
not
on the screen but for years now we've
also have
the paper coming out the bottom of the
machine
uh which basically falls into a bucket
that really no one looks at
and six seven years ago when i was on a
commission looking at charitable gaming
we went to the various halls six of the
halls and the ones that had it
no one no one looked i actually placed a
bet
two bets looked at it the the result was
right on the screen
i didn't look at the piece of paper uh
other than just uh curiosity at the end
saying
what does it say so some information
that i got
since the committee hearings on this and
work sessions
is that during during the peak of covet
when they allow these halls to open uh
the the company that makes there's only
one company that manufactures
the paper that comes out of these
machines and it's in canada
and they were closed for many months and
the
i guess the lottery allowed these
machines to be played
without the paper coming out the bottom
because there was no paper
that met the criteria here
so
is it i guess when you when you think
big picture
i know there was a reason years ago for
the paper
uh but no one looks at the paper coming
out the machine and it kind of seems
wasteful uh and and again we we
there's really only one there's a
special kind of paper that's used or
something and uh
so so that's what this does does this uh
the sponsor of the bill
wanted this piece to component of the
paper coming out the bottom
machine of the electronic machine uh to
be
ended then the second portion of the
bill
is increasing the size of the deal
uh the commission shall not authorize
deal sizes over 14
000 tickets currently they're 3 500
tickets
and the reason the logic for this is to
be able the larger the deal
that their ability to offer bigger
prizes
trying to attract more people uh to
to play this currently
uh they are some of the some of the
locations are
uh they're being allowed to uh
if in this case uh do four deals in one
at a time in these machines
so it kind of already exists
so i don't see any reason why
and i'm sure others have reasons why
they don't like this
but what all it does is increases it to
14 000 ticket deal
which will allow larger prizes to be
offered
thus attracting more players thank you
uh representative elney
thank you mr chairman i've got the same
objections to this one that i
had to 27 uh
about not waiting to look at proper
regulation
for what has become on
near slot machine electronic gaming that
is going to be all over the state of new
hampshire
on and
[Music]
without the state getting hardly any
money from it
without the charities getting a whole
lot of money from it
but um with the addiction possibilities
all over the state of new hampshire on
so on my
other major objection to this is that
it was the lottery that decided to allow
that
electronic uh recording
of the winnings would show up on the
screen
so that the tickets would not no longer
slow down
the machine to keep it further away from
being a slot machine it was supposed to
be a dispensing machine
and the legislature authorized it that
way
it has moved from that the 14 000
is an extra way of trying to make this
a lot more like a slot machine and
yes we've kept the the little paper
napkin
over the thing by keeping the slot
machine illegal in this state but in
fact we have legalized them
so um i'm i'm objecting to this one
i'm still trying to decide if i want to
force it onto the regular calendar or
not
thank you any further comments
i don't see any further comments so
representative bernstein would you call
the vote on
senate bills 22. certainly mr chairman
thank you
the roll call vote on sb 22 the motion
is ought to pass as amended
we'll begin the roll call vote before i
begin
uh just a reminder that when you cast
your vote we should be able to see
your smiling face and hear your voice so
uh
make whatever adjustments you have to
for that we'll begin the roll call vote
with representative patrick o'brian
yes thank you representative jordan
owerry
the clerk votes yes
john jeanigan yes
representative tim baxter yes
representative thomas c schamberg
representative schamberg votes yes mr
cork
thank you sir representative edith
tucker your muted representative
yes thank you representative jenny
gomarla
yes
representative amanda gorg yes
looks like you got a good set up there
representative
representative mary hacken phillips yes
representative james murphy yes
there you are all right and chairman
major
yes
mr chair there were 20 members voting
one member voting no and three members
not voting
the motion carries with a vote of 20 to
one
on i think that
i said most of what i wanted to say in
the other blurb
and what i want to say about the lottery
is not going to be acceptable in a blurb
so um
so we'll go on the consent calendar
before we go any further i just want to
review
we've had a total of 10 senate bills
all of them except for senate bill 3
which we're going to
senate bill 23 25 27
48 101 and 103
all passes ought to pass and a couple
passwords amendment and the blurbs are
all
in senate bill 112 and 139
were retained by the committee
unanimously
and uh i'll need a blurb on that
representative romney
so all we have left for our blurb
is senate bill 3. but
take up the concurrences before we go
into senate bill three
mr chairman can i say one thing please
i just want to i just want to thank
representative representative janae
again who's in california right now
for waking up extra early at their
three-hour difference
to be with us today
and don't go away yet because we need
okay the first concurrence
is on senate bill 306 relative to the
revenue estimates while operating
on the emergency orders caused by the
covert 19
pandemic
and the amendment
that the senate put on it was amend
section one of the bill by inserting
after paragraph two of the following new
paragraph
which says paragraph three the chairman
of the house ways and means committee
shall
notify the chairperson of the senate
ways and means committee
of any meeting convened in accordance
and i don't
have any problems with that um i don't
know if
any committee members have a problem the
way the senate
amended this doesn't
anybody want to speak to that if we
i would say we concur mr chair
representative
[Music]
speaking as a prior chair
on there have been a number of things
like this stuck
onto into the law in the past
and nobody has been responsible for
reminding or telling the chair that they
were supposed to do
acts and i'm wondering if there's any
way we can set up a system to remind
and i guess that may be a question for
on
if jennifer four is with us at the
moment
jen did you hear that uh yeah i did hear
that i'm not sure exactly how
um you know what kind of like tickler
system
we could create for something like that
but i think it's
certainly a good point because there are
you know
different responsibilities that exist in
law and
there's not that i'm aware of any good
way
of bringing a new chair up to speed on a
um
related to this that um we frequently
run
into is that we've put a sunset
on a tax or a fee
uh in order to look at it again and then
the same chair or the next chair uh
several years later or 10 years later
uh doesn't know that and somebody all of
a sudden comes to us
and says the thing is expiring
maybe maybe legislative services could
think about that
somehow that's a
good point representative romney i mean
representative
um so you've heard of
does anybody else have any concerns
if not i think we probably should take a
vote
represent bernstein thank you we'll
begin the
the uh vote on concur or non-concur
with uh rep reminder please have your
video on when you cast your vote
representative patrick abrami yes
i concur thank you representative jordan
o'leary
yes representative russell ober
yes
representative fred ducette yes clerk
votes yes
representative herschel nunes yes
representative tim baxter yes
representative susan almi yes
representative dennis maloy yes
representative thomas c schaumburg
representative schamberg votes yes mr
cork
thank you sir representative edith
tucker
yes representative jenny gomarlo
yes
representative amanda gorg yes
representative mary hacken phillips yes
mr chair 21 members voted yes three
thank you representative bernstein and
i'll report that
the next is house bill 330 relative to
sports
and the senate concurs of the house of
representatives in the past
the following entitled bill or the
amendment
what's book retail operations
and essentially what they did
the house passed version there was a
no more than 10 sports what retail
locations may be in operation
at any given time the senate took that
out
and so that
the commission and his agents are
further authorized to operate
physical sports retail locations within
the state
for the purpose of accepting tier 1 2 2
and
tier 3 supports wages and authorized
betters and paying prizes relating to
those wages
the sports board retail locations may be
co-located with other commercial
businesses
or general commercial retail locations
so essentially all they did was remove
no more than 10 sports but retail
locations may be in operation at any
given time
normal comment representative early
and i would move to concur with this
bill
okay any comments uh yes mr chairman we
spent a lot of time arguing
arguing about this last time the
original
bill on i think took that
out and we put it back in
so i don't know where people are with
this though
the whole i listened into it and
the on and actually i
talked at it i explained what we've been
talking about that
if there are is a limit of 10
then uh we actually are likely to get
more of these sports betting locations
because
um it costs quite a lot of money to set
them
up and the entrepreneurs will look at it
and think
okay i'm not going to they're not going
to be 10 of us
in manchester so that we'll all lose
money
um there and
on it will be more likely that more more
people will show up who will want to do
it
and the senate doesn't seem to
understand this kind of thing
and thought that that someday i mean
they did ask the lottery and lottery
said
we've only got two and we might get
three and it's highly unlikely
that we're going to get to 10 for a fair
number of years
but on so they decided that
you're restraining competition and
therefore
we shouldn't uh should take that out
uh so that's that's what the senate
side of it was unless they made some
more comments
at another time mr chair
romney yes actually i actually agree
with
representative romney on this uh we did
uh we did take this out of the original
bill and then they added it back in
what we wanted to preserve was the tier
two betting
for the brick and mortar locations
there's two right now
i guess there are three other
consideration
actually lottery wants to control this a
bit they don't want these everywhere
they're trying to control how many of
these i think we got that from lottery
what i would i would recommend not
concur and ask for committee a
conference so we can have the discussion
with the senate on this
so that's that's another um
i don't know if it's a motion or
whatever i know we have one that says
let's
i think you have to take some kind of
straw poll here right we have two
recommendations here
one is to concur and one is non-concur
from a committee of confidence
uh representative i will go ahead with
the uh
non-concur committee of conference uh
it's if you want to have a discussion
that's fine i think the senate's
position on this
is whenever you put place a limit
like 10 sports uh play locations
we ran into this discussion when we were
talking about um
the um casino project
we run into an issue regarding
establishing
by eliminating the number of locations
and allowing to quote
smith the hidden hand of the market to
control which ones succeed and which
i i i think that's a better idea but i
will go ahead with the uh
committee of conference okay
representative
yeah i i uh concur with uh
representative grammy's approach which
is
non-concur and request a committee of
conference
um basically because uh
i think the uh it's not an issue right
now we've only got two or maybe
a potential for three uh locations
and um if uh time passes and it becomes
evident that
that the number should be a good reason
higher um then that's the time to
consider it but this
uh we're just starting out on this this
is an issue that's been
looked at closely through all the
processing of the
sports booking and sports betting
system and we've always as a committee
come out
on the side of of including this
limit the 10 locations
in the bill is a reasonable limit beyond
what we expect to happen
so i i i'm
absolutely open to having a dialogue
with the senate
and maybe they've got some points to
make that would uh
would be persuasive but let's take it to
that
forum to uh sort this out
about senator bromley yeah that's where
i want to remind the committee that this
bill passed
not this bill the the original sports
book bill
passed two years ago some of you weren't
around
and we we purposely put
10 10 location limit in that
original bill this bill really the
primary
reason for this bill is to do the tier 2
for some reason we left tier 2 out for
the more brick and mortar locations
uh and that's definitely we definitely
definitely want that to pass
uh so you know
the 10 to 10 was not the spirit of the
original
going more than 10 was not the spirit of
the original bill is is what i'm
i'm basically pointing out thank you
any further comments
saying none uh representative bernstein
would you
call the vote on the motion of
non-concur
thank you mr chair uh just a reminder to
have your video and audio going when you
cast your vote
let's begin the roll call vote on the
non-concur motion
not concur asking for a committee of
of conference as to the motion concur
[Music]
representative overy please unmute and
and show us your
we'll come back to representative
holdery representative ober
what was that vote that was a
representative uh your clerk
representative berstein
will vote yes representative
yes
say that one more time for the record
thank you representative tim baxter
yes representative walter spillsberg
yes representative paul tudor
yes representative susan almighty
yes representative richard ames
yes representative dennis malloy
yes the honorable
and outstanding representative thomas c
schaumburg
you make me smile mr clerk
representative schamberg votes yes
thank you sir representative edith
representative james murphy yes
before we ask the chair let's go back to
um yes
jordan worry thank you mr clark you
oh my apologies representative gomarlo
mr chair there were 18 votes
in the affirmative two against
the motion carries shouldn't that be 19
there's i think there's 21 here
right we have 18 yes two no and three
members not voting
we have let's go through correct me if i
haven't eat something wrong
abrami love hillary voted yes
ober doucet voted no bershteen voted yes
elliott did not vote genigen
nunes baxter spillsbury
tudor all vote yes almi
ames vote yes southworth did not vote
malloy and schamberg voted yes
i don't have tucker's vote um for the
record representative tucker
yes thank you and i've got marlow voting
yes loftman not voting
gorg hacken phillips murphy and major
voting yes
so that's 19 yes votes two no votes
and three not voting
do i have it right now 19 yes
thank you thank you representative almi
for calling my attention to that i
apologize
the next one is going to be a little
i sent our gen had sent a side by side
on all three of these
and if you look at the side by side on
you'll see under the notes on the first
page both versions reference rsa 287
in paragraph one and the senate version
adds reference in that the paragraph
that follows
rsa 287 was repealed in 2019-83
and
[Music]
five thirty three heard back in valley
canyon at the lottery regarding the rsa
reference problem
and section one of the bill looks like
the reference to rsa rsa287
and so what we need to do is be able to
in order to correct this
is to non-concur and form a committee of
conference
in order to be able to correct next to
rsa
287d
any further comments on that
uh yes mr chair uh first i agree with
that and
we obviously i think we need to do that
um
when this bill was originally part of
the uh historic racing bill when it got
pulled out
we created a separate bill we neglected
to
because 284 is
racing statutes 287
are games of chance statutes
and they the uh after the bill got
passed
uh the senate picked up on this that
didn't we want this for charitable
gaming as well
and i i i fully concur with that that it
should have been it should have been
the racing statutes as well as
charitable gaming so
so they put 287 in but they put the
wrong reference as as
representative major said they put the
wrong reference should have been 287d
so i think i think we need to fix this
so representative romney
you make the motion non-concur from a
committee conference
yes i do
any further questions or comments on
that
yeah yes is there's a lot of other
material we only got this
last night and i was in a zoom
last night and haven't had a chance to
understand all the other stuff that the
then uh would like to hold this off
on could tomorrow
representative i think representative i
mean i chime in mr speaker
mr speaker mr chair yes
i i think do you do whatever's around me
i think i think in any event we're going
to need to go to committee conference on
this
and we're going to need i think we have
time to strategize among ourselves
our position when we get to the
community conference
so i think just giving giving the senate
a heads up that
we do want a committee a conference uh
earlier later it's probably better i'm
not i'm not
entirely sure that on i'm because
maybe jen can tell us on there were a
whole lot of different
on crossings out and underlines and she
didn't mention them in the side
version if she did it so so maybe
um maybe it's identical
in all other respects i'm not sure
yeah if there are if if there are no um
gray highlights or notes
then they're identical so section two
is identical and then you'll see notes
section
3 was inserted by the senate we didn't
have
which i believe has to do with
the sharing of responsibilities between
the attorney general's office
and the new role that is established by
this bill
and then there's a slight change to the
language in
the senate bill section for house bill
section three
um regarding how they talk about
fines and penalties and i'm not exactly
sure what how those terms um
change things for the lottery commission
yeah i i found that part very confusing
when i tried to look at it yesterday but
i can't
talk to you and look at it at the same
time because i don't have it printed out
so maybe
we could discuss it at some point to
strategize
like you were saying my biggest problem
is that there was a major adverse
report against liquor commission
enforcement during the time that this
bill was going through
and uh and a lot of people seem to be
extremely upset by whatever it was but i
haven't had a chance to read the audit
yet
and i don't know if anyone else has
thinks that that it creates any problems
for this if representative
brownlee has read that audit and
talking about the uh representative
you're talking about the liquor
commission audit
yes uh there was another bill that we
dealt with that did something with the
liquor commission
but this is this is a lottery commission
bill
doesn't it say i thought it was liquor
commission enforcement within there
i'm going to have to go back and look at
that thing again it's lottery
it's it's the lottery commission asking
for a division of investigation and
compliance
we did have a bill we did have a bill
had to do the
liquor commission uh i think
i think that's what the confusion is
yeah not that bill though
that and the fact i think you were
running that bill so
it's well yeah that was my
okay thank you i'm sorry i totally
understood that
piece of it no problem we want to
proceed
on for the motion non-current form of
media conference and work this out
i'm okay with that representing your
league
yeah i was just going to say that in
looking at the language
all it does is bring it into a
typical language that is used for
setting up uh
rules and regulations for enforcement uh
particularly the enhanced penalty
section
it uh requires um that the paragraph
three that jen was talking about or miss
four was talking about
um it doesn't do much of anything
other than uh just make it very similar
to language that is used for liquor
commission
um and that's the the comparison between
the two
that they're similar language but it's
my reading of it is that it's an
entirely new division yes it's growing
government a little bit but
the way the gaming is growing in new
hampshire
it's something that uh i think uh
its time has come so our committee
conference thank you sarah good day
you know uh mr chair our bronzing you
know there's a few places where they
change the word
uh the subject's fitness to
the subject's suitability and
fit suitable this bill i think went to
uh
edna correct after us that was that
amendment was in edna you're correct
representative
because i don't remember those changes
so that's why those are identical
because
edna made an amendment to change that um
a matter of fact just this uh
representative major and and uh in uh
chair
say again man carolyn mcgowan mcguire
right carol mcguire
uh i have to come up with uh the
concur not concur decision but
but um but we i guess we want to give
representative major guidance as to
which way we want to go and um carolyn
mcguire
chairman mcguire had said that
this was okay but once i had
jen do the side by side
rsa 287 didn't exist anymore
and that had to be fixed so yeah
mr chair the only way we can fix it is
to go to committee conference correct
right i'm gonna i'm gonna have to
discuss this with carol because
he doesn't know this yet
and once she sees this i'm sure she
will agree to non-concurrent former
uh mr chairman aren't you the primary on
this
the primary i think it was waves and
news i believe
uh i'm not sure i'm gonna have to look
we've got it one way either first a
second
but the edna uh amended it
after we saw it apparently right
we went first mr chair we went first
this was a
we were the policy committee on this
right
then the dna and then the senate got it
so you out vote carol
if necessary but i don't think she'd
object
i don't think so either so
house bill 533
uh and for the comments on non-concur
and former committee of confidence
i don't see any hands ready so
representative bernstein you want to
certainly uh this was moved by
representative abrami
mr chair i don't have a second on this
right now put me on
it i put susan on
okay we're degenerating a bit
all right roll call vote on the motion
is
non-concur and the committee of
conference to the savage committee let's
begin the roll call vote with
representative patrick abrami
yes representative jordan ovary
yes representative russell ober
yes representative fred ducette
yes clerk votes yes
representative john genigean yes
representative herschel nunes yes
representative tim baxter yes
representative walter spillsbury yes
representative susan almighty yes
representative dennis malloy yes
representative thomas c schamberg
take my hat off to your representative
bursting yes
representative edith tucker you muted
representative
yes thank you representative jenny
gomarlo
yes
representative amanda gorg yes
mr chair all 21 votes cast were
thank you representative bernstein and i
will be in contact
chair can i just make a comment
representative romney
just want to thank jennifer for uh jen
four for her
uh eagle eye on this one and finding the
error on the 287
we have some real good researchers
all right next
voting mode i was going to say executive
number one we'll be hearing from
the chamber of commerce
people both small and larger businesses
relative to the ppp loans
their application for it have they
been approved as far as being forgiven
and like anything else
let's see miss brock
who will talk to us about the
rules on the
american recovery act where we can't and
can't
do with the funds and that's extremely
important to us
all right now i'd like to go into
senate bill 3 on our word session
mr chairman yes representative brunt uh
i
don't know could i ask
when are we going to hear from the dra
on on they were talking about
on telling us
the timing on the uh ppp
well there's the yeah there's the timing
on the ppp there was
there was uh something oh they helped
they'd promise to look into for us
to kind of help define the difference
between
what's associated with our excess
revenues
due to the ppp loans and
what's associated with
excess excess revenues to the
other types of stimulus packages that
are with
more like one-time stimulus
and that they're going to have that
ready for tomorrow
and are we going to go into the
afternoon i've got
what i'd like to do now is is
one of the questions people have
relative to the ppp
loans so that we can get them addressed
because our time is running out we're
going to have to make a decision next
week
on what we want to do on senate bill 3.
uh representative
billsbury has a proposed amendment
and he's done a lot of work on this to
me
it makes a lot of sense of what he wants
to do
so representative spellsbury you want to
go over
sure thank you mr chairman i
think committee's heard plenty from me
so just a very quick
thumbnail and then any questions you
um
basically the purpose of the amendment
is to ensure that expenses
which have already been used the first
time
to qualify the loan for forgiveness
would not then be permitted to be
deducted a second time
after the ppp forgiven
grant is excluded from income would not
those
expenses would not be allowed a second
time
to offset other income which remains on
the tax return
so the purpose is to avoid a double dip
it does as a matter of math and tax
impact
essentially offset uh
the initial purpose of sb3 so
and it's it's really that simple you
don't get to use the same expense
twice and so
if we don't amend uh senate b3 in the
fashion that i've described
we're not really rectifying or wrong
what we're doing is we're providing an
entirely
new round of stimulus essentially
so i i hope that's clear any questions
i'd be glad to try to answer
representative tucker yeah i'm so glad
to have a chance to
ask you a question of representative
spillsby very impressive the work you've
done
but uh the states that
automatically conform to the irs rules
they do have the ability to double as
you put a double dip
is that not correct yes
those those states that have
conformed and taken action remember
the the federal government acted in two
stages
in the cares act they provided
that a ppp loan once
forgiven which ordinarily would then
become taxable income
can be excluded and therefore simply
not declared as income on the tax return
on the federal tax return
it's not until december when
congress further acted that they
clarified that the deductions remain of
the expenses
remain available to be deducted against
other income
and as i understand it that lives
outside
the internal revenue code so other
states in various ways
have taken actions to conform those that
are fully conforming
are in effect uh making the decision to
allow a further round of stimulus
by allowing the deductions to be used a
second time so i think the answer your
your question is yes uh the question is
whether we should
and i would just point out
that in some very very helpful
information that representative aims
circulated to us
you can see that other states have taken
intermediate steps to
mitigate the impact the most notable
examples
that i'm recalling were that california
made two qualifying net changes they
said that
the deductions could be taken unless
you're a publicly traded corporation
and second the deductions could be taken
only if 2020 revenue declined by 25
or greater from 2019. so california was
not just allowing anybody to take the
deduction they were trying to
steer it where they thought it might be
most needed
and virginia took a different tact
they said you can take the deductions
again but up to a limit of a hundred
thousand dollars
so effectively small companies large
companies could share
a a new benefit up to that ceiling of a
hundred thousand
but if you had received you know several
million in ppp you were still limited
uh to 100 000 in terms of the second
uh use of those same expenses as
deductions
i hope that clarifies well i was
could i follow up mr chairman
so what i was concerned about is that if
we're too different from
other states does it put our new
hampshire companies
at a disadvantage since we're in a
a competitive situation always as a
business
with other states particularly here in
new england we're pretty small states
um so how
how do you address that issue
that being so different from other
states may put our
own businesses here in new hampshire
at a disadvantage competitively
so i think it's a very good question um
to start with we all do tax businesses
differently and businesses
know that when they engage in each state
second
uh our bpt tax is not only being
assessed against
you know new hampshire domiciled
companies but all the companies that do
business
in the state including multinationals
and large
conglomerates and multi-state operations
so
um i don't think that there's a clear
cut answer to your question except to
say
that every business that operates in
multiple states operates under multiple
systems
and the other thing this isn't directly
what you ask but i just want to remind
everybody
that the biggest difference between new
hampshire and the other states i think
is that virtually all the other states
have a mechanism uh generally through
personal income tax and uh supported by
sales tax
to recover a substantial portion of
whatever they choose
it chose in this context to allow the
the businesses to keep ultimately gets
recovered substantially
in personal income taxes and we don't
have that mechanism
so we don't have an offsetting way to
recover
what we are being asked to give
and if i may interject uh representative
tucker
this is what representative spellsbury
said
is exactly right and also in addition to
this
which is a very important fact is
new hampshire gets about 30 percent of
its revenues
through the business taxes our
surrounding states
vary from close to five percent of their
revenues
from the corporate taxes
so corporate tax is extremely important
in new hampshire much more so
than it is to these other states i
have to remind you again new hampshire
is different than alderman
doesn't have taxes or income tax to
recover these
these losses uh representative
brandy thank you thank you mr chair
um well representative spellsbury knows
my position on this amendment
uh it brings us back to the original law
it brings us back to original law
namely it negates sb3 so we're going to
call something sb3
that has the same tax impact of we
didn't vote for sb3
i'm i'm concerned that businesses are
smart enough to see that
for us to imply that we're doing
something for for uh
businesses in terms of keeping the
stimulus the stimulus
impact uh that was put in by the federal
government
uh uh i i think it
it doesn't have a good appearance to us
that it's
it's better just to vote no on sb3
uh and and go that way then to vote
an amendment that that may sound like
we're doing something but we're not for
the businesses
so that's my position on the amendment
and uh i want you to know that there are
a lot of businesses watching us right
now
uh everyone this is a hot bell
and uh i think i think i've told the
republicans this i don't know if i
mentioned this to the full
car the full committee two weekends ago
i got a call from the
uh the uh one of the founders of aroma
joe's
those small coffee places that are
popping up everywhere
and uh aroma joe's he owns 17 of them
personally there's a whole bunch of them
that are now they're now franchising
aroma joe's the original owner the
original founders
uh and he he said i'm shocked he goes
i'm shocked that
that new hampshire was supposed to be
very business friendly
isn't go it hasn't acted already on this
and this this is this is now
jumped into the world of politics
that's my view uh and uh
it's they saw what the federal
government did they just assumed
probably falsely that we new hampshire
conformed they don't know about
conformity
they just assumed that we were going to
go along with the feds
and uh and the one thing that he's
brought up that was new to me
was he that his for his businesses
for his various shops the big issue for
business right now is not finding
employees
one of the things that they plan on
doing with this
stimulus if you will if we if we vote
for
sb3 is to actually
uh provide bonuses to hire people
to get people we have 35 000 people who
are
on unemployment roles that need to come
off those roles
and one way is to incentivize them to
come off the rolls and that is to
provide bonuses signing bonuses uh
to to work uh and and get some of these
businesses
opened again fully um and because that's
our biggest problem right now is finding
employees
so uh so again there is
i thought that was an interesting
insight for me i just want to share with
everybody
uh but i i i respect 100
respect representative spillsberry i
think he spent a lot of time and effort
on this
but i i think the uh in terms of the
amendment
i think that we it's i don't think it'll
have a good look
if we pass the amendment and then pass
sp3
because there is no stimulus there's
that if we
we deleted any benefit to the business
is
by passing sp3 it's it's it's it
the the amendment just neutralizes uh
and it's it's basic instead of getting
the money from one pocket it's
not getting a formal pocket we're going
with one pocket to the other pocket
and uh it as and representative
spielsberg did admit that
yes it's uh impact is neutral
and uh in terms of uh it cancels out
the second stimulus and uh
and that's all we're talking about here
and just to add that was the deliberate
intention of the
amendment right but i'm i'm more
concerned about the optics of that
and if we think about it a while
businesses
not that i'm probably not going to i'm
probably going to be voting for sb3
but i i think for us to vote for sp3 as
amended
it's better to vote it down sb3 down
without the amendment
um because it just appears that we're
doing a
you know a slight of hand if you will uh
and providing a an sp3 that doesn't have
the benefit that the businesses thought
they were gonna get a hundred percent
now virginia or some of these other
states that you mentioned
there that those amendments actually uh
yes it trimmed down the benefit they
trimmed down the benefit
and only and it and it uh
was more focal focused on certain size
businesses
whereas this we were just it's just an
optics thing that
if if you don't like sp3 then vote it
down uh but
um i wouldn't go this route of the
i can just reply briefly i concur with
everything
i concur with everything that
representative abrami has just said
uh most particularly i think the final
analysis this
will come down to a political judgment i
think the most
important uh goal
of my amendment was to make sure that we
make our decision
fully informed clear-headed about what
we're doing
and understand that this is uh
incremental assistance over and above
not right or wrong but i do think that
there are intermediate measures and
that's why i brought up the california
and virginia examples i
frankly i find the virginia example of a
hundred thousand dollar limit
uh very appealing and that would
address i think in part your point to
representative abrami that
it doesn't necessarily have to be a case
of doing nothing or neutralizing it
totally there's an intermediate way
of trying to shape who gets the benefit
well i would agree with you on that
that's different than the current
amendment
okay thanks um i guess first i want to
say i
i both appreciate and admire the work
that representative spillsbury has
has done for the benefit of all of us
and
thank you for that um
representative spillsbury s said that in
effect this
uh allowance of the deduction deduction
without
limit constitutes amounts to a
further round of stimulus and i don't
think that's
quite right because i think
that we're talking about a federal
policy here
that as part of its stimulus
uh what we're talking about here at the
state level
certainly uh the understanding that most
states
automatically conform to the ir
see whether it's within the
contours of the irc itself or as
affected by legislation like this
legislation from just outside the code
doesn't really matter the
federal the federal stimulus which is
significant ppp has been a very popular
encompassed i think what we're talking
about here
the substantial majority of states
have bought into that concept either
maybe unwitting wittingly or without
much thought
but in any event they have in fact the
we see the numbers if anything of states
can conforming going up
um california came in late as as noted
with
uh with some restrictions uh
tamping down the stimulus vermont uh
seems to
be reversing itself that that report
just came
to us the other day maybe yesterday
and so
stimulus yes is not a further round i
think it's
federal policy that we're talking about
here and it's
in the context of a pretty
serious uh jolt to our economy
overall that this is uh responding to
um i wish we had better data i think
there's another point that really has to
make be made we're
we're really lacking information um
we're talking also about what is the
fiscal impact of this
uh this um
situation uh generated by pvp
and whether or not the forgiven loans
will be counted as taxable revenue
and we're engaged in a massive
uh effort at guessing uh what the impact
will be
um if you reach dras uh
fiscal note from start to end you'll
have to read through the first half of
it which is why
it's uh an estimate why why really the
revenue impact is
indeterminate to use that for that word
um and then uh having said all that
uh dra boldly
launches into a uh
an analysis that results in what the 99
million
dollar impact that's it's now projected
um but there are a lot of assumptions
that
lie behind that and we don't seem to be
able to penetrate
the wall of uh no information
sufficiently to really get a handle on
what
what really is going to be the impact
and it's unlikely we will for a while
so i want to make that point with regard
to
new hampshire being different from other
states yeah we are different
we do have the bet that was not
mentioned
so there is a tax on on the wages
that that does counter for some of
the effect here i would characterize the
revenue that's coming that would come if
we don't change current law
as in the nature of a windfall
to the state it is
uh anonymous it is one time
whatever way you want to characterize it
um
and it was not predicted in our uh
revenue estimates uh that we did very
recently
we didn't make any explicit
add-on for this phenomenon
uh yes we talked about the federal
stimulus to our economy
in general and i think that led to more
optimism
and higher revenue estimates but we
didn't
talk about a one-time surge that we
had a sort of a spike that would
then fall back down that wasn't part of
our estimates
so if we go along with sb3 as written
we will simply be um
acknowledging that the spike is
is probably there getting back to my
data problem
but is probably there and then taking it
away
so revenue-wise have
uh maybe momentarily been
been dazzled by the surge in revenues
and then we'll go back down to where we
were
when we entered into this discussion
so for for all those reasons i'm i wish
i i'm still looking for data information
um i'm somewhat intrigued by the
possibility of doing
something like virginia did i don't
think we could do what california did
with public
companies just because of constitutional
issues where you can't single out
different
uh corporations based on that kind of a
feature i'm not sure that but i think so
um so um so possibly
we could cut into this and maybe that's
reasonable
but there again we're lacking data and
who are these uh sort of bigger
corporations that
uh above the hundred thousand dollar
number
um that uh maybe shouldn't get this
uh get this money without taxation
um i don't know wish i did
so that's sort of where i'm at i'm still
in flux on this thing um looking for
information
thank you representatives representative
thank you um one thing i wanted to
mention
was i separated out the corpse from the
proprietors and partnerships
uh and the little extra that i don't
really understand
for the bet and the bpt in the triangles
um or rather the data that went with the
triangles
on 2017 and 2018 18
is when we got the big spike from the
last federal tax
on the our equivalent of the corporate
tax which is the bpt
uh was 19.4
of the bpt
that on and it
in 18 it jumped to 24.7
so from what we know about the big
corporations
this time or what we think we know uh
it's going to be
up there again around a quarter it isn't
when you separate out the proprietors
and partnerships
that other states with income taxes
usually
or always tax their business income in
the personal tax
um so there is a difference from what
we were thinking about that
but and another thing i'd like to agree
with
representative abrami about the optics
of it
on i get requested
for information from 360
on a fairly regular basis they're
probably going to be after me again this
afternoon
uh they're after some others of you too
but they say
you have to reply by five o'clock and i
usually don't even notice them
by then um but i have
talked i did talk with them last time
and
and they are watching like a hawk
what we're doing with sb3 and they're
spreading it around the country look new
hampshire hasn't made up its mind yet
um but um
and that that is a pro big problem for
us
um the chambers
tomorrow i hope they're going to be able
to provide
some clarity as to who actually might
benefit from this thing i don't think
that
the businesses do a number of them
pay know what they're paying tax on
and what they would get out of this and
the fact that they can
oh yeah you can deduct the expenses i've
had various
indications on that one that that
they really hadn't figured that out that
they could do it already
but there there seems to be no way
to get that education through last fall
there was a bia summit and
it was revealed at one of the sessions
by three
ceos that they pay no attention to
what their taxes consist of they just
know they have a
total tax bill from water district
up through feds of x
uh so i'm not they leave it to the
accountants
so i'm not so sure
that they know when they complain to us
that they know what they're talking
about
and at least one of the chambers
got back to me from an earlier email i
sent them
and said you know they'd been
complaining to me about it so i sent
back to them
these were restaurants to ask them
[Music]
if if to tell them that look you can
deduct
the tax the expenses
and then you're you're also
if if we pass sb3 you're going to get
extra but you can already deduct the
expenses so you don't get minus
uh and um they haven't responded yet
so she doesn't really know the answer
she can't tell whether they're just too
busy opening up
or whether they're um
their uh hadn't thought about this
so that's a real problem for us too
because they're upset but they don't
know may not know what they're upset
about
and what then that they don't have a
reason to be upset
the i would like really like to see us
doing something
to the along the virginia
idea because i'm really
i think that probably most of the large
corporations that
send us the most money have a lot of
subsidiaries
i don't know dra is actually in the
attendees i don't know who
which dra but um if
if their form the forms that come for
water's edge
include or not the uh
the identification and finances of the
subsidiaries
uh so that we'd be able to
to know how many subsidiaries they've
got the subsidiaries would have been
able to apply for ppp
the the parent companies probably not
they would have been outside the
acceptability level
because of the number of employees yes
but if
if they have a lot of subsidiaries then
those
our biggest taxpayers are going to be
taking a lot off for
ppp when we do this and i think we're
gonna probably have to do this
but um that's that's my thoughts at the
moment
um
you got both of us at the same one that
was pretty good
at least you had an equal name of
opportunity
all right sorry about that
[Music]
representative
jordan yeah i'm trying to get this thing
to work
um one thing we haven't talked about
that was alluded to is what would happen
if we
don't pass this bill in the current
situation if i understand this correctly
what would happen is um
a business would receive the ppp money
and then that ppp money if spent
according to the uh general operations
of a business
would then be deductible as a business
expense so the offset would be
negligible or the cost to the business
would be negligible
as was said earlier this is a political
decision
as to whether or not we want to look
like we're doing something
but in fact we're not really doing
anything
except giving a little bit of money to
somebody
uh what uh spillsbury was talking about
is the adding the extra amount of money
as a deduction for a legitimate business
expense
uh as i understand it um
yeah the reason that businesses receive
this money was because of
direct government activity and yes
the government is now trying to make up
for being
uh overbearing i'll be polite
and closing down a lot of businesses
so that's the question what do we want
that's the way i look at it if we want
to look like
you know if the real fact is
we're not doing anything but we're
passing a law to do something
and if we look like we're not doing
something we look like we
and we'll be called bad people
i mean we've all been on on either side
as to
whichever power political party is in
power we all use that argument
here hey we all get to be on the
receiving end of that argument so
i'm done thank you thank you
representative
representative romney followed by
representatives
i mean thank you mr chair i mean there
is a difference if we pass it and not
if we pass or not pass the one thing
that's the same is that
a forgiven loan or the money used from
the loan
uh to hire people or spend it on things
or keep people employed
in either event whether we pass sb3 or
not is
deductible as a business expense
the only test but if we if we boo pass
sb3
the forgiven loan okay the forgiving
loan then becomes
revenue and if we pass
sb3 that revenue is not taxed
if we don't pass sb3
the revenue will be taxed that's the
that's what we're talking about the
difference
that's it right there so that's that's
the sum of what what it is the deduction
is always there no matter what we do
it's on the revenue side whether the the
forgiven
loan which becomes revenue whether
that's taxable or not
so i just wanted to clarify that's my
understanding if someone has a different
view of that
please let me know but that's that's
been my understanding all along of what
we're talking about here
thank you let me just quickly say before
we go to
reference again is that
they get the loan they use it for what
it's intended to
it's not taxed what sp3 does
it gives them another
exemption so they get it double tax
benefit that's the question
i think it's the other way around i mean
it's it's been exemption
the if you look at the bill it only
talks about the revenue part of it
uh the it's a deduction no matter what
okay what we're talking about is that
it's if what if we don't pass sb3
that that forgiven loan which is
becomes revenue on the books of a
business
is taxable revenue if we pass sb3
that that revenue kind of goes below the
line way below the line
it doesn't count as revenue it doesn't
get taxed when you when you have when
you're
when you're doing your tax this is legal
i'm about to say
companies have your regular books and
you have your taxable books if you will
and what things that are taxable are not
taxable but so on the taxable books
that that hundred let's say it's a
hundred thousand let's say it's a
hundred thousand dollars
in the forgiven rev uh loan money that
became revenue
with sp3 it's not taxable so it
basically
doesn't show up in profits uh that way
of uh but it shows up in the books as
profit
you know the as revenue after expense is
profit right but
on tax books if sp3 passes
that revenue doesn't appear in the
revenue part of the books
it it it's it's it's
it's basically i mean it does but then
it on the bottom it gets deducted out
as a taxable revenue so
that's all we're talking about um so
um can i jump in and clarify that please
yeah go ahead representative spellsbury
there are there are two components to
sp3
paragraph one says
no amount shall be included in the gross
business income if it was forgiven ppp
so i think what what representative
abrami is getting at is its revenue
but this mechanism says
your cash books and your textbooks can
be different
on your textbooks you don't add you
don't
declare that forgiving ppp
as a gross business income
correct that's what but if if if
sp3 only contained paragraph one we
wouldn't be having this discussion
um it includes paragraph two
dot dot dot by reason of the exclusion
from gross income
you would think if you're going to
exclude the forgiving ppp for an income
all of the expenses that qualified it to
be transformed from a loan to a grant
would be set aside with it so the key
to paragraph two is to say
no all those deductions you just used
shall um none of those shall be denied
that's why they're free to be used a
second time so i i just think
let's not oversimplify it this bill to
do what it's trying to do needed both of
yeah but i i okay my understanding
though
is that if we don't pass it that you're
telling me what you're saying to me is
that if we
don't pass this bill
that that those forgiven ppp
uh won't expend the expenses from the
forgiven loan are not deductible
because i think they are deductible um
and i think i think the paragraph two
there was
just to make sure that we we didn't
change anything that currently exists
but
that that was always my interpretation
well i think i think what you're saying
is technically correct paragraph one
says
we're sweeping away the income
side and paragraph two says but we're
not sweeping
away the deductions with them i think
carolyn lear said it very very
beautifully last wednesday
when she said let's take a couple of
steps back
is the ppp program under
current law revenue neutral and the
answer is yes
but the consequence of sb3 should be
very very rough about the numbers
if the business tax generates about 800
million
if about 60 of it is bpt
then of the 480 million approximately
that's bpt we're proposing
to relieve or
refund 20 to 25
of our entire bpp
chair can we we have d.r.a this way in
this last conversation
representative romney yep we have others
want to say something all right i just
thought we were on this topic that we
could get a clarification on what we
just discussed well maybe later
and carolyn and the dra will be here
tomorrow
and they're also listening but
again if the companies
that apply for the ppp loans
use it for wages
and associated costs associated with
wages
they get to deduct the whole thing and
pay no taxes on it
what senate bill two three does
is allow another deduction by
saying
you can deduct it as
wages again so you've got a double
says that that that it says that the
revenue is not taxable that says nothing
about the deductions
right revenue is not taxable versus
being taxable
well senate's ability passed but without
senate bill 3
they got the ppp loan they wouldn't be
paying any taxes on it
if they use it as intended for wages
and expenses right absolutely we're
assuming in this discussion that
that that that's there that they used it
as intended i agree
okay let's just go to
representatives
thank you thank you mr chairman um yeah
i first just want to
also thank representative spillsbury for
all the work he's done on this
um i think it raises important points
however i will echo what i said
um about a week ago i think this is
this is going to become political but
also i'm going to add to what i said
before
after hearing representative abrami's
information about aroma joes i think it
raises a
really important point because it's not
just aroma joe's
i'm sure many of you have read in the
news that many
corporations are having trouble hiring
people because of the extended
unemployment benefits
so it's um i think we have to take that
into account
in this whole uh process as well because
um we've got to make sure that i think
businesses
are going to in fact i've read that as
well that they're already starting to
offer higher wages to get people to come
back and say hey you know
i know you're collecting great
unemployment benefits
but i need you back we've got i think it
was 17
000 job openings in new hampshire
roughly at this point so i think
i think we should that aroma joe's
example i think is just a tip of the
iceberg for many
corporations and
at this point my vote will be to vote
for sp3
thank you uh representative elmi
[Music]
thank you mr chairman i'd just like to
mention first that there are a lot of
other reasons besides the unemployment
benefits
which is a
small piece compared to what
parents are going to be getting
as education as child credits
on but that the the people
that were in the fast food restaurants
that were
in the regular a number of the regular
restaurants
that are were serving in retail
know that if they come back to those
jobs they're going to be working on in a
situation
where a number of people
are approaching them
without masks they don't know whether
they're vaccinated or not
a lot of those people have health
problems
on they've been forced to work in the
past because they had no alternative
through health problems including things
like flu
i've had complaints from people in those
jobs
on and um right now they can just barely
afford to survive on unemployment
and they're doing it a number of them
others of them
had retired from the workforce and
aren't planning on going back partly
because as you get older you're more
susceptible to catching things
on so that's i just wanted to bring that
up
but what i wanted to ask about was
if the dra could tell us whether it's
technically
to audit or to
to to evaluate tax returns that come in
saying that we we spent
so much of the of of our
usual deduction for our worker expenses
or our rent
on was was paid for by ppp
as versus from what profits we managed
to
to get or from something else because
i'm wondering whether
it's it's possible to distinguish those
enough that we could even
even do this though it's in a very
interesting
thank you representative
further comments or questions on senate
representative talkers i want to know
whether the
major concern that most committee
members have
is that we would not have as much
revenue
as we would otherwise have
there i mean you can look at other
revenue sources rather than moving
rooms and meals down to 8.5
it could stay at nine i mean is it the
revenue that people are concerned about
or is it somehow the idea that we're
benefiting
companies that really don't need the
benefit i
i guess i need to understand people's
motivation what is it they're most
concerned about
maybe a couple of people would be
representative romney would you uh take
over for about five minutes
right back okay and i had my hand up too
so
so uh here's the thing
the one question we have to ask
ourselves is how is the state doing
right now and i would say that the
state's doing well
very well revenues are great but we know
as a committee specialist
we know that a lot of us representative
ames was pointing out earlier
that the the the good march in april
that we had
had a lot to do with the extensions
that were filed and that the the the the
guidance that they got from
their uh businesses got from their
accountants uh tax accountants were
that you gotta you gotta base your
estimates on
current law not on sp3 passing because
it hasn't passed yet
so we know a lot of that money is out
there
and uh my big concern i i think
you know we're way ahead over 200
million and i i don't know what the
we know the revenues really well we
don't know how uh the bottom
you know how uh under budget we are
because we don't know the expense side
maybe someone here does know
uh that but revenue-wise we're over
200 million so far this year
even with the uh taking care of the um
the uh anomalies from from the year
before
so i i think we have the money to pay
for this
uh my only concern and i've expressed
this to to
some of our leadership uh in the house
uh
that that we can't spend this money
we gotta we gotta we have to find a way
of making sure that money stays there so
that we can pay for
when when the tax if we pass sb3
some of this money has to go to pay for
the uh
for the uh for the actual
uh uh refund checks that have to happen
as well as people not paying quarterly
uh they're gonna choose you to
take the refund or they're gonna do the
credit carry forward
thing so there'd be less quarterly
payments going forward
so but we already kind of have that
money in the bank
to pay for this and it's just a matter
of not spending it
in the next budget so that's that's my
position on it
and i've already expressed that to the
finance chair and to
anyone who listened to me if i told them
if sp3 passes
we just gotta don't think this is a big
chunk of money sitting there
that we can start spending on other
things i think some of it has to
go to uh refunds
and as well as less revenue from uh
quarterly payments for a while
so that's my position and i see
representative
majors back so i'll let him take it back
over
thank you representative romney and
tomorrow we're going to be hearing
from the dra on this excess
funds that we have right now and the
business taxes
i've mentioned this before is how much
is associated with the ppp loans and how
much is associated with
many other stem stimuluses that
are generating one-time funds
so we have to make sure that we
utilize these and set them aside to be
utilized
as either one-time expenditures or
for refunds if senate bill three passes
as
is representative spellsbury
had mentioned what virginia has done and
you
might want to consider something similar
to that
and because nobody ever
gets exactly everything they want five
their legislators being able to
negotiate and compromise and coming up
with something that's
good for most situations
if i may i'd like to explicitly confirm
that i'm wide open
representative let me see i have
thank you um i would like
to get clarified whether if we
pass sb3 as it is
on the surplus statement
how much money will be saved in the
surplus statement
uh by lbao and whether that
that they can be instructed to save a
smaller amount or not
i don't think they can but
that we know not very much of this is
going to show up
for 21 taxes it's going to show up
or rather the taxes that are coming in
in calendar year
21 they're going to show up in calendar
year
and then more of them is going to show
up again in calendar year 23.
and we need to see how
how that's broken down and how much of
it is going to
be in calendar year 23 because that
in calendar year 22 and 23 because
that is the part that would be in the
surplus statement they would ignore
anything that's coming in later
um and
[Music]
and i think that that's that's the most
dangerous part of this i would i would
i am of two minds if we discover that
there are a lot of subsidiaries
in these mega corps that pay most of our
tax
business taxes on that
would that we would put a cap
on how much they could could
avoid paying taxes on
for the ppp because i don't
i don't know how their finances work
among the subsidiaries and
and the general one we we know in the
case
of heineker uh heineker no
budweiser in in
uh new hampshire that they
are under this this doggy
dog competition among the subsidiaries
of budweiser
all over the country and and that
um if they show show
up with less revenue they get
um yet less
of the operation as the way it works out
which is i think not usual but it may be
normal
in subsidiaries of very large
corporations
so uh that that one worries me a little
if we put a cap on it but i would love
to put a cap on it otherwise
thanks okay before i go to
representative ames tomorrow
the gra is going to be talking
to us about the various calendar years
is how um
the ppp money is going to show up
over the next four years also i've asked
them to take the surplus statement
and carry it out that they could for
four years
beyond flight 22 and 23
because the way that and
it is in house bill 2 most of the tax
reductions that we have up front are
far in weighted we don't see much of it
happening
in 22 more than 23 than 24.
we need to see what
we do how will affect the future
and so they should have having this
information for us tomorrow especially
the timing
on the ppp loans and hopefully they'll
be
able to give us more information on this
stimulus
representatives thank you
um yeah first uh
um i i guess i want to clarify that
if sb 3
passes the
impact relative to current law that
would be
go into a surplus statement would be
negative not positive um
we'd be losing revenue theoretically
as i said before i don't believe
estimates to date of revenue
have included
the current law increase
that many believe is happening right now
current law taxation of ppp loan
forgiveness
but um but nonetheless i'll be
interested to see
how i'm sorry about the telephone how
the
surplus will be handled um when the
surplus statement is
is indeed issued reflecting both that
reality of the lack of estimates
on this issue before and then the
impact relative to current law
theoretically
of of an sb3 change
and then the other point is
is just responding to a comment made by
representative rami and then i think
properly
broadened by representative major
we we don't really know
if ppp is the cause of a substantial
cause of
the surge in revenues that
we've just seen particularly with the
extensions
we don't know whether that's ppp or it
could be some other phenomenon
there have been a number of firms who've
benefited significantly
in this downtime for most businesses
it's been an uptime for
some businesses and and we're talking
big money
um in
just a few business instances
so it's a public report we can talk
about it uh about the
major gun manufacturer and what is it in
newport
um that uh
their their profits are have searched
and we all know of other large
businesses
that are in similar situations so much
so
that it would have an impact on our
revenues and
maybe that's creeping into both
estimates going forward and
payments of last year's
tax due on extensions
so i just want to put that big question
mark up
uh in front of a lot of assertions that
are being made around
thank you representative um
could i reply that representative
yeah dick and i have been arguing about
this
what i am focused like a laser on
is the final budget on
revenue estimates and
the house when when the senate puts in
more money
the senate usually wins most of it
uh during the committee of conference
and uh i
i do not think that the senate would
hesitate
to to increase the revenue estimates
because
of what is coming in unless we create
a large noise about factors that are
involved in that
that are ephemeral thank you
um let me just add to that i've been on
a number of
committee conferences on the budget
on the revenues we would get together
as senate and house ways and means
and go through the revenues and we would
come up with an agreement on
it wasn't one-sided it was usually
we came out with a compromise that we
agreed on
most of the time representative
bromley i think mr chair
on in terms of our revenue estimates
um as you look at the calendar
um i mean we have the session on the
third and the fourth
uh is the plan to have uh the
last official uh quote-unquote official
ones that we
we want to mention for the record
on the house floor to be those days or
do we have until
the 10th can we also do that on the 10th
when the day that the committees of
we will have revenue estimates
right up to the committee of conference
so that means
can we get those officially mentioned on
the floor
on the 10th which is committee of
conference formation day
we will do that okay so is that the plan
then that's the plan
whether it's whether it's a house
resolution
or my announcement
okay yeah i was thinking the house
resolution when i said official
um okay but that's but that's what we're
shooting for and then the other thing
is is how do we want to
it gets a little i guess we can need to
talk about with this with the dra
uh as we do our revenue estimates uh
how they come up with their latest
ranges given all of this
with sb3 and
how do we want to deal with it in terms
of
the budget i i guess the surplus
statement is the way to go
and do our normal projections and then
say that this is an anomalous
if we pass sb3 this is anomalous and
uh and then we have to take our best
shot at
estimating what what the revenue loss in
future
years would be so anyway i just wanted
relative to the stimulus package
and so it run more in the range of it
on current law and on
the current situation without
uh the stimulus
subtract the stimulus
we'll have chris back from lba right uh
in some of these sessions when we talk
about revenues yes we will
because i think we need to possibly seek
some guidance as to how to best show
he will be with us all the way okay very
good
[Music]
well i've got a question about next week
could you give us an idea by tomorrow
about
on which days we're going to work how
long
that is into the afternoon so that
or or next week we won't be doing
six i guess we won't be if it's june
10th we won't be doing
we need to get senate bill three out
our work will be done on bills once we
finish senate bill three
and then we'll constantly vote on
revenues right up to the committee of
column
we have been working tuesday wednesday
would we start working thursday again as
well
i think people have been filling
schedules
next week let me just take a look at the
calendar
i'm going to have to do the powwow
with the lba gallery
and um but plan on
tuesday wednesday and thursday we don't
need to
be a gift
of representatives tomorrow i
just wanted to answer edie's question um
my concern is that if we do pass this
bill
that we're going to let some of our
bigger businesses off the hook
and we will have to return a lot of
revenue
but my other concern is that some small
businesses that didn't expect to have to
pay
the tax um are going to scramble to come
up with the money
in the coming months or year or next
year
so that's where i stand eating
have filed with extension
who will be in it but that
covers the first stimulus
the second stimulus
finishes may 35th they ran out of money
about the middle of may that
will actually be reported next
that timing issue is going to be talked
about tomorrow
by the dra they've been working on that
so we'll know more than
um i do worry about it
and i have no idea how many fit in this
how many businesses do you have out
there that
applied for the
um
part of it's been fixed because the
first weekend
since you were you business of last year
this year you couldn't you couldn't
apply for it
because you couldn't do more or
those businesses are usually out of
business now
and they're really really something
but
what we try to do is try to
pass out laws so it's fair to
everybody and
um
what i heard today about
addressed this maybe you might want to
seriously consider what the
did
[Music]